hey guys it is Wednesday and dance 6
though I'm alone like stay for alone but
I have going all primitive technology on
you I've set up all the gear press the
big red button on the camera and written
the entirety of the script on my own
selfies all goes to crap you'll only
have me to blame I feel like that was
happen
Portland's developer gearbox has
revealed they're working on a new
project and since I don't want you to
get upset with me down in the comments
I'll tell you right now it's not
Borderlands 3 I know I'm disappointed
too but enough of what it isn't what it
is is codenamed project 1v1 a berth
person shooter that offers up first pace
FPS combat alongside the meta game
strategy of a collectible card game you
did absolutely hear that one right after
conquering the combo of RPGs and
shooters with Borderlands the studio are
now ready to blend card games into the
mix there aren't any more official
details beyond that nor is there a
trailer which is why you've been looking
at two concept art pictures for a really
long time I'll just change it to bottle
ends there you go anyway the games
website does make mention of a short
closed technical test that's scheduled
for this summer you can sign up now
anywhere in the world but service will
be hosted in North America so it may not
run perfectly in other places the test
will consist of three game modes the
cooperative challenge mode arena where
you take on the current arena champion
and ranked where you fight a similarly
skilled opponent wins grant you with
experience and crates full of cards
platforms are yet to be laid out but the
beta signup process does mention the
need for a Steam account
so our clever deductions have led us to
believe it's probably going to be on PC
at least in news of why we can't have
nice things a recent update for Friday
the 13th is going to stop letting you
kill your teammates because apparently
that's the thing you keep doing if you
know anything about Friday the 13th the
game it's probably that it consists of a
team of camp counselors trying to
survive a hellish evening being stalked
and attempted murdered by Jason but I
guess some of those camp counselors get
a little panicky with a weapon in their
heads because some players have been
deliberately killing each other so many
in fact that publisher gun media is
stepping in the publisher explained
while the mechanics intent is designed
to promote life-or-death experiences
into each and every game you play
the reality is turned into more of a
battle royale scenario to a point our
team feels a change needs to be made so
come the next patch you won't be able to
hurt your friends with weapons in public
matches but you will still be able to
run them over with a car because you
know otherwise someone would just
in front of the car and block it because
circling back to my first point this is
why we can't have nice things
finally Eurogamer got their hands on the
ps4 5.0 update release notes early so if
you don't want spoilers block your ears
cuz I'm gonna tell you what's in it
Eurogamer reports that the 5.0 patch
will include the ability to stream 1080p
gameplay at 60 frames per second over
twitch using a ps4 pro as well as the
new system where you can now follow any
PSN member and not just verified
individuals like developers of course if
you'd rather not be followed you can
close yourself off to non friends or
block your parents in your privacy
settings the report also indicates that
notifications and upload downloaded
statuses can now be seen from the quick
menu that's accessed by holding the
PlayStation button and there are new
tools for parents to manage what their
children have access to on PSN the 5.0
update still doesn't have a release date
but that beta is Judah Lent sometime in
August that is everything we've got for
you today do let me know what you
thought of today's episodes what your
thoughts are on today's stories and I
will see you again tomorrow
ok so stupid automatic we're about
blinds